fit approves three quarts of basis point
height to rate uh take rates to highest
since 2008 hints at change in policy
ahead this is a CNBC story and a
well-telegraphed move the markets have
been expecting four weeks the central
banks raise its short-term borrowing
rate to three quarters of a point uh to
a target of 3.75 to 4 Points the highest
since January of 2008 the move continued
the most aggressive pace of monetary
policy tightening since the early 1980s
the last time inflation ran this High
the new statement hinted at the policy
chain saying when determining future
hikes the FED will take into account the
cumulative tightening of monetary policy
the lags with which monetary policy
affects economic activity and inflation
and economic and financial developments
economists are hoping this is much
talked about step down in policy that
could see a rate increase of half a
point in December meeting and then a
smaller fewer hikes
2023 this caused the market they
announced this late and a market tanked
it went from being down 20 points to
being down 500 points within literally I
think 30 minutes or so so Tom when you
see this what you're learning with this
rate hike they announced yesterday well
what you have to remember is when they
say what when the typical person reads
well Telegraph what that meant was the
banks that make the mortgages were
expecting this because remember the
mortgages move at the bond market and
the mortgage-backed Securities what the
average person needs to understand is
that the interest rates affect those
first then the mortgages so the
mortgages about a week ago were sitting
there like
7.375 which is seven and three eighths
to seven and a half is where they were
and this morning I went in there and I
looked and I said what are they
adjusting because they had built in some
of this three-quarters of a rate
increase but what they heard Powell say
is there's probably another half Point
coming in December and so that moved
things this morning and I looked it up
if you're a person typical in the United
States we were just talking about this
hold it up type in Google mortgage rates
yeah mortgage rates today and you'll get
the uh and by the way Tom you have to
realize this three quarters of a basis
point increase doesn't take into effect
with rates for another week or so so
people are going to see an increase next
week maybe the following week yeah so go
ahead perfect this is it right here now
move the credit score just take it down
to 680 690
at
7.891 you are knocking on eight now
let's say I've got a little bit of
credit card debt and I've had things
going on during the pandemic just take
me to 650. not need not anymore than
that but just right to 650. terms 8.327
so the banks are drawing a line if you
are below 650 right now which is not
horrible credit below 660. if you're
below 660.60 not horrible credit you are
at eight and three eights three seven
five that's where you're sitting right
now which means this is put in
perspective now we're talking rates and
everything and let's put it for the
typical person you bought a house Vinnie
yeah last March say for half a million
okay three and a half percent loan
your payment Was Eighteen hundred bucks
pretty reasonable I would that's my rent
now if you try to buy that same house
right now
five hundred thousand dollar house four
hundred thousand dollar loan and you go
out and you get a seven point
eight percent interest rate it's three
thousand dollar payment on the nose
twelve hundred dollars more which means
and if and if you said to your bank but
I can only afford eighteen hundred and
they said okay that's fine just go find
a house that's worth three hundred and
ten thousand dollars oh wow do you see
what just happened for your same
eighteen hundred bucks with that
interest rate yeah so that is a ladies
and gentlemen a 40 drop in buying power
for the American Consumer it's real this
is not speculation this is not patent
Tom talking about the future this is
reality right now so if your job is
moving you to another area people have
said in the comments well what do I do
you know what's in it for me what should
I do
if your job is moving you from one part
of the country to the other first of all
you're going to have to Discount your
price on the house you got right now
it's probably up a bit get out from
under it and then under consume housing
on the other end get yourself a lease
and get small space make the kids share
a bedroom for a year and a half two
years and that's how you're going to
have to weather the storm you don't have
any choice on it go lease lease less
don't let your pride and your you know
it's crazy time you're saying this
you'll be back yeah you'll be back but
just surf it out I gotta so I get when
we anytime we talk about things like
this a lot of friends and family and
people that follow the content that are
loyal to it who are in the real estate
Mortgage business they message us listen
and here's how it all starts Pat I love
all your content except
you've been going after us realtors for
too long man and this is like not cool
and I'm like look I understand you're
not happy about what we're talking about
but here's what I will tell you with the
current messaging that we got going on
this is here because of printing fake
money for too long yesterday Tom and I
were talking I said okay when is the
next time rates are going to be around
five percent okay so we're actually
doing the math together so then we pull
up and we say okay how long is this guy
going to be in the the chair of a Fed
Powell well he got elected when May of
last year 20 May of this year 2022 by uh
Biden because you need because he
doesn't he doesn't really report to the
president but you need the president and
certain amount of people to get him to
say we want you to stay as a chair of
fed right Senate votes him in yeah the
Senate and the president's the Trump
Administration he was he was so he was
re-elected but the point is the point is
reelected Not Elected right he was he
was re-elected by Biden so Biden kept
them in so this is not a Republican or a
Democrat type of guy this is a guy that
both of them are like dude he's not
listening to me he's not listening to me
what he does how's the vegetables you're
right so he doesn't take Council from
Trump he doesn't take counsel from by
Independence we like that you as the
consumer believe me we don't have enough
people like that yeah you know when his
next term is going to be up it's going
to be May of 2026 which means the next
time rates are going to be at around 5
it's probably going to be Q3 or Q4 of
2026 if that and this six percent above
could stay for a long time and that can
become the norm here's the challenge
this morning I was looking up an article
by Wall Street Journal I want to send
some of these pictures to you and I
don't know if you guys knew this or not
but Federal Reserve has assets and
liabilities okay they have both assets
and liability on their balance sheet on
their balance basically the fourth
branch of government if you want to
think of it so when you say that they
buy their own
company their company so Tyler I'm gonna
airdrop this too if you can pull this
that goes down to the premise of
quantitative easing quantitating
tightening that's how they kind of limit
the money my nose is going to bleed but
quantitative believes but typically
typically what they've done they've
stayed very neutral it's been very
neutral so all of a sudden when they
started if you can pull this up I don't
know if you see it or not if you got it
I want to show this it's very insightful
on how to Fed works pull up all three of
them if you can so go go to the first
one I sent okay zoom in a little bit
that's the balance sheet the other one
the balance sheet of go to yeah the
balance sheet of the FED here's what
you're looking at zoom in a little bit
if you can I don't know if you can or
not so okay here we go on the asset side
that 5.61 trillion dollars of U.S
treasury Securities t-bills tables
exactly short-term bills okay and then
they have 2.69 trillion dollars in
mortgage-backed Securities that's the
MBS I talked about that's right that's
what you saw in big short so again 2.69
trillion mortgage-backed Securities is
it is it the same way to explain time
like a reinsurance right like how Munich
reality smaller insurance companies they
go to a Swiss tree and they're the inch
Insurance the reinsurance that's backing
them up so 2.6 trillion dollars it's the
Jenga scene from The Big Short
yeah
that's right and then other that have
0.48 trillion which means they have
roughly 8.78 trillion dollars of Assets
Now liabilities currency and circulation
which is interesting because currency in
circulation is 2.28 trillion dollars
okay
Reserve balance
3.04 trillion dollars and other is
another 3.46 trillion dollars for a
total of eight point seven eight
trillion dollars okay go to the next one
this is the scary part of what's
happened to them go to the one priority
that I just showed you yeah right there
so the earnings of Federal Reserve sent
to U.S treasury for the last 12 years
okay if you look at that this is the
first time they're in the negative
how is the Federal Reserve in the
negative do you realize for 11 years
straight this is very interesting fact
for 11 years straight the Federal
Reserve has netted 4 to 11 4 to 10
billion dollars every month let me say
that one more time every month to
reserve the Federal Reserve has netted
four to ten billion dollars except for
this month
look what happened right there boom drop
off and then something bad happens yes
and then if you go to the other one I
sent you I don't know if you got another
one or not there was a third one I
wanted to show you which is very very
interesting when you look at this I'm
sending it to VT MacBook Pro so just
come straight to you I don't know if you
see it or not if you got it and there
you go there you go if you can pull that
up check this out so this is how it
looks okay the green if you look at this
the green is treasury Securities cool
the light green is mortgage-backed
Securities at the top
the dark red is currency in circulation
and the light rate is bank reserve and
then white is other right go prior to
2008 prior to quantitative easing it's
very normal not a big deal they didn't
get involved they just kind of weren't
there you know they didn't do nothing
they were not manipulating the market
they were not manipulating the economy
and then they say there is this thing
called quantitative easing let's get
involved so they got involved oh [ __ ]
okay now we're in too deep and in 2020
oh [ __ ] covet oh what are we doing now
now it's like getting off of this this
is why when people sit there and they're
like
no this is not going to happen real
estate is not going to take dude there
isn't a better definition of fake
success for this many years and Powell
who right now has got a very very hard
job because anybody that's hated by
Republicans and Democrats is probably
the most honest man in America okay this
guy is not Direct by anybody yeah no one
likes this guy the left doesn't like him
the right doesn't like him heck the
people in the middle are confused they
don't know if they like this guy or not
but all he's saying is guys we can't go
like this for too long so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]